Massachusetts judge will announce this
morning whether girl's text messages to
a friend are responsible for his suicide
eighteen-year-old Conrad Roy took his
life in July 2014 investigators later
found thousands of texts from his friend
Michelle Carter on his phone
many messages encouraged him to kill
himself
48 hours correspondent Erin Moriarty has
been following this manslaughter trial
and she's at the courthouse in Taunton
right now Erin good morning good morning
Gail Conrad Roy's family members have
been waiting nearly three years for this
day they're still trying to make sense
of why he didn't talk to them about his
suicide plans but turned to someone else
the person Lynne Roy's son Conrad did
reach out to was Michelle Carter a young
woman he befriended on a Florida
vacation both teenagers were struggling
emotionally Michelle suffered from an
eating disorder while Conrad had
previously tried to take his own life he
spoke about his depression in this video
he made I'm 18 years old
and I still haven't recovered from
social anxiety depression it's
controlling me they bonded over text
messages Conrad confided that he had
suicidal thoughts and in the weeks
before his death
Michelle's responses were disturbing I
thought you really wanted to die but
apparently you don't
I feel played and just stupid and then
eight days later Conrad got into his
truck you can't think about it you just
have to do it he died from carbon
monoxide poisoning after purposely
breathing in fumes prosecutors indicted
Michelle Carter for involuntary
manslaughter making the case that even
though she was more than 30 miles away
Carter's texts were so convincing to
Conrad that she was virtually present
when he took his own life
and you can commit a crime
via chest Michele's attorneys argued
that Conrad was acting of his own free
will
this is somebody who wanted to
eventually take his own life it was his
decision you know I have no idea what
the judge will do today but he may be
the best judge to make this decision not
only is he a retired juvenile court
judge but he taught high school English
for 12 years he knows teenagers gale all
right sounds like he's the perfect
person for this job Thank You Aaron very
much you can see Aaron's full report on
this case tonight on a special 48 hours
it's called death by text it airs at
8:00 7:00 central right here on CBS